so I watched this Candace on the
documentary documentaries are [ __ ]
they should be illegal dude 100 you
should need like FDA approval a license
or something like your license that's
way more dangerous than a gun don't let
people do documentaries give everybody a
gun no documentaries will be fine I
agree I don't trust you I don't trust
documentaries because you have however
many hours of footage you edited down
into the most 90 convincing minutes you
possibly have of just your side no
documentaries like hey one side says
this and the other side says this so you
picked your own truth and see what it is
this is the facts 90 minutes back to
back edited down hundreds of hours of
footage let's take the 90 most crack
minutes the most fentanyl minutes put
them into that 90 right there 100 and to
also when I was getting all the backlash
on on Instagram or YouTube or even DMS
and [ __ ] they were saying all these
things and this happens all the time
when like people believe it have like
these Fringe ideas right it's like they
know so much about their Fringe idea
that you don't know so there's nothing
you can say right like when people talk
about UFOs and that kind of [ __ ] they're
like well technically the way that the
flight pattern was going I don't know
about flight patterns yeah you're right
you can say anything to me that you know
more about than me 9 11. I can't push
back I'm not a structural engineering so
the thing what am I supposed to say no
that's not how beams are yeah right I
might be onto something exactly so
that it might have been you know if
Candace always put our 911 documentary I
believe I believe in 911 yeah yeah you
don't believe in it now honestly before
9 it went 9 10 9 12.
00
so Candace made me believe in numbers
so she puts out this this documentary
right
and her point of the documentary was and
also I blame Dave Chappelle for this
[ __ ] because she was like I wasn't going
to do this until it became personal and
she played that Dave Chappelle clip of
saying she got a stank [ __ ] mad time
I think that hit her bro okay I do think
because that's for women that's you know
I mean especially if they guys stinky
[ __ ] that's a real [ __ ] yeah I'm
not saying she does don't make me
up
I think that [ __ ] smells great I think
that's it I think it stinks allegedly
you think it's a legend yes well there
was one allegation thrown out there yeah
okay and she makes this documentary
and the idea of the documentary is
essentially that black lives matter is a
is a scam a fraudulent organization
that's the craziest Theory I've ever
heard in my life now we've there's a lot
of evidence to prove that that is true
now okay uh if you watch that
documentary you will believe it
they got 90 million dollars they give in
2.5 million to like Toronto trans
organizations right they're given
millions of dollars to their friends
like this woman Patrice colors who runs
the organization right [ __ ] that [ __ ]
say what you said that that she set back
the movement decades yo because [ __ ]
that
[ __ ] ass [ __ ]
I'm telling you say your lettuce yeah
yeah what do you want to do bro what do
you want to do oh wait let me cook up I
hate that [ __ ] though I hate her more
than Kenneth told me wow yeah I see that
yeah illustration because without you
even texted the group said she said that
uh she set back the black empowerment
movement decades because it's gonna be
very hard for the average person to
donate it to this thing to believe in
the future that the same thing won't
happen right so I understand that
completely right
um
but so what she's doing is she's
exposing later on the documentary she's
like where all the money goes she's like
tracking it because you have to file
these IRS reports right so you can see
where the money goes if you're a charity
you don't have to pay taxes but you got
to show what you're spend the money on
right so they're going like she hires
her brother to do uh baby daddy to do
security she has her brother to do the
video stuff which we would all do you
know what I'm saying like that's the
thing we would like I give him a little
bit of pushback on that regard like if
you got 90 million dollars I'm gonna
hire y'all do you know what I'm saying
our cost is the head of I don't know
haircuts or something you know what I
mean like whatever it is you're gonna
pay about 1.5 million a year for that
job yeah exactly at least all the money
around but at least when you get caught
throwing a run money around to the
homies you just go ah you got me yo yeah
they still play the victim I'm being
attacked I can't believe Candace Owens
is out here doing all this [ __ ] so I
could see the frustration with that
especially uh with the people who
already didn't [ __ ] with black lives
matter so if you already don't [ __ ] with
black lives matter and you see that the
the organization was invo involved in
some scammy [ __ ] yeah now you're like
she was living in like a five million
dollar oh they bought property
everywhere yeah math properties
what yeah they gotta flip it show
there's no way yeah
you can't even say black lives matter
without giving the disclaimer it's like
oh I'm talking about the movement not
the organization like statutes yeah they
[ __ ] the whole thing yeah yes now so
you go you see all that that's very
convincing and also very frustrating
right
there's the George Floyd part and her
issue with Jordan she says that it's
fence and all they kill George Floyd
that's what she's saying and then
there's a lot of people who haven't even
watched the documentary they just
[ __ ] heard that narrative and they're
just running with it and it's so obvious
now I've seen the documentary okay now
the big issues I'm learning are now is
the way that Chauvin had his knee on
Floyd's neck he wouldn't be able to
choke him out now yeah that makes sense
you're not gonna choke somebody
by putting your knee on the back of
their neck you've never seen anybody do
that in [ __ ] Jiu Jitsu right you
choke Somebody by going like this and
pulling right so what people are are
jumping and I go well I guess he must
have died because of the Fentanyl
and and we're going to get to another
point that I want to get to in a second
Phantom on the system yes they also say
and that they pick up the most specific
words they're like he had a lethal
amount of fentanyl in the system you
don't know what's lethal to somebody
yeah okay we're at Burning Man there's a
lot of people had lethal amounts of
drugs in their system it did absolutely
[ __ ] nothing for a week you know it's
illegal to this man these guys probably
love rock music and like Keith Richards
has done a lethal amount of every drug
exactly exactly especially if you are a
user your tolerance is going to be way
harder you don't know exactly what it is
and furthermore these are the same
[ __ ] that during covet they're
like oh they're over uh over reporting
the amount of Cova deaths
you're old and you die and you have Cove
in your system it's because of covet you
have a heart attack and you die because
you have covet in your system it's covet
they blame everything remember they're
like this is the government they're over
reporting it they want us to be scared
Etc if you have Cove in your system
doesn't mean it's a covert death there
are other comorbidities that could have
killed you and the second fentanyl is in
George Floyd but that's the only way
that [ __ ] could have died of
death it's offensive if you got feds on
your system nothing sits on your neck
for eight minutes straight while you say
you can't breathe it must be fentanyl
I'm not this the only reason that's a
heat Ass Point all I'm saying is so so
keep that same energy up one of those
you got to take all that [ __ ] back about
the Cove of deaths yeah and say the
government's 100 right in that which I
know none of y'all will do [ __ ] your
mother's nose in my [ __ ] okay or or
or you gotta say you're full of [ __ ]
with this fentanyl thing which you are
now I think that fentanyl does play a
part in it
so George Floyd had this enlarged heart
with an enlarged heart you need uh he
had this other [ __ ] thing I don't
know I'm not a goddamn scientist we can
look it up but basically it's harder to
get oxygen to your system when you've
got a guy compressing you he didn't die
from being choked he died I think from a
pulmonary heart attack or so
cardiopulmonary some [ __ ] [ __ ] I want
anybody to breathe with a grown ass man
putting all his [ __ ] weight on your
[ __ ] back exactly
and he was already complaining about
that he couldn't breathe yes so it's
like the guy broke all protocol because
whenever you're arresting somebody if
they talk about hey I'm having uh health
issues you're supposed to treat that he
didn't even try acknowledge it at all
100 and the guy wasn't George Floyd
there was a point where he wasn't even
moving for a long period of that time
yep so there's no point to have your
body on him to restrain him anymore you
only do that just to make sure once he
is and you're saying this is you've been
in law enforcement you know the actual
rules just to put this out there sorry
so you know I'm not saying this is good
that you put it out there what you're
saying is is what you were trained to do
when you had to resist people so it's
like you we were taught that yes the
knee on more so like the back area to
just if somebody's trying to resist the
moment they stop resisting right now you
take the pressure off right exactly now
they're gonna make the argument that he
was resisting he was resisting tons
throughout it I'm not going to discredit
that but what's very interesting to me
is if if you're purely looking at him
being choked with the knee of course
you're going to disregard the whole
thing and say it must be fentanyl if
you're looking at a guy who isn't able
to get the amount of oxygen that he
needs in a system because of a heart
issue as well and you're applying
pressure on him while he's on the ground
restricting the amount that his lungs
can move yeah that's what leads to death
you know that game I don't know if you
guys play this for your kids but like
you go up against a wall you put your
arms like this you take a few deep
breaths and then your friend pushes on
your chest and then you pass out yeah we
literally did this game
yeah and what do you do you pass the
[ __ ] out now imagine you just kept doing
that for eight minutes straight you
don't just pass the [ __ ] out yeah you
die yeah yeah okay your mother what
about their mothers you know what about
about their mothers I forgot you know I
gotta help her up after she sucked my
dick from the back okay got it that's a
suck my dick in the back I forgot are
you on your knees if they're sucking
from the back or are you just don't bent
over okay okay I'm dense over responding
to the comments okay
y'all ask where your mom is at
anyway so uh so yeah that's that's my
reaction that and and what I would say
to anybody who commented or anybody was
seeing it go watch the documentary that
you suggest just simply go watch it yeah
and find out the exact cause of death
they're going off the [ __ ]
narratives as well what I will say this
is the the way that the mainstream media
reacted to it was to call it a choke
they use this language and they didn't
describe what happened in the most
honest way with which left the room for
other interpretation right if they were
just honest about a dick listen this guy
had a large heart he had fentanyl in his
system which is going to increase uh not
only blood pressure but your level of
excitedness yeah or whatever and uh
cause you to have more anxiety and when
you have more anxiety you need more
oxygen in your system and he doesn't
have the heart that can kind of pump
that through so uh but the main catalyst
is this grown man [ __ ] laying on you
yeah right so it's like if you just
simply laid it out like that now of
course they don't want to lay it out
with that because they have one
narrative want to push right so I'm all
about you going hey [ __ ] the mainstream
media can choose a narrative and then
run with it no matter what we've seen
this happen time and time again but to
act like the opposite of that narrative
is true simply because we know the
mainstream media can put out falsities
is also [ __ ] yeah this isn't the
example to prove that with exactly
because then you're going with the
alternative that he was killed by fennel
and he just wasn't exactly did it play A
Part Store you don't know how much uh
yeah and canvas acts like she knows how
much you have done Fentanyl
[Laughter]
he died on May 25th would he have made
it through May 25th 2020 had there not
been a someone's knee on Earth yeah I
mean even one of
the one that they try to use they try to
use the thing that he says for like the
opposite information they're like he
goes uh he goes was there a lethal
amount of a fentanyl in him they go he
goes uh he goes
um I would blame this death on fentanyl
if he was just at his home doing nothing
yeah yeah and they tried to use that as
a way to score points for them yeah no
dummies I know there were points in that
duck that like they refuted it and they
didn't realize it or were they trying to
be balanced no I know yeah yeah
the guy's saying I can't breathe because
he's claustrophobic that's what
claustrophobia is yeah I feel like I'm
gonna run out of oxygen yeah yeah I will
say that Jordan Floyd did did do some
[ __ ] that didn't make no sense like what
when they they pulled him out of a car
and they tried to put him in a bag of a
car and then he was like I can't go in
the car I was like well you was the
Zipcar nah you just feel trapped bro
that cage there yeah hands are behind
your back you just feel like I can't get
out of here if it's my car I get up walk
out no problem if I'm stuck in this
squad car in a [ __ ] cage
I know because I'm claustrophobic
homosexual as well
I'll say noses no no no my
my closet is so small and I can get it I
get an elevator with all y'all but if I
got an elevator and it stopped for 30
seconds I would freak the [ __ ] out like
you've never seen before yeah like I you
would all lose respect me forever if you
had it to begin with it
freak the phone this is sword for fun
for 50 minutes in between stations and
then like the court the doors are locked
so you can't go in between I was falling
apart I had no cell phone service I was
just [ __ ] sitting here diabetic next
to me pissing on the train at one point
I'm like
in this New York don't give a [ __ ] I'm
like guys are we gonna get the [ __ ] out
of here and everybody's like this
[ __ ]
that's why I got it right on the top
dude
let's go let me do that [ __ ] I'm comfy
on top exactly I need the air in my
mouth
but I don't get the implication of this
people are like oh are they trying to
say that Chauvin should not get the
charges that he got I'll send the the
funniest part is that before that oh
yeah I would never know him to do
anything like this don't they say that
about every murderer and every [ __ ]
documentary ever seen yeah no I'll be
honest I don't think that he his
intention that day was to go out and
kill something
here's what his charges were they were
second degree unintentional murder third
murder second degree manslaughter yes
yeah that's I think that we can all
agree that those are accurate so if we
acknowledge George Floyd had a large
heart and Fentanyl in the system and was
also had a guy's knee on his neck does
that change even call it back people go
that's what I'm saying it don't matter
he had weight on him his chest was on
the ground right do you remember when I
was in the [ __ ] uh when we were at a
ship these party at Six Flags and they
put the goddamn uh roller coaster [ __ ]
too tight I made them stop the thing and
open it because I couldn't breathe I'm
like George Floyd yeah it's to me
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
let's talk about that but do you want to
button up this topic yeah yeah so uh I
want to say one thing there were mad
people that that reached out and they're
like yo Schultz I think you got this one
wrong so I [ __ ] with you I think you got
this one wrong I respect that I respect
that because that means that you
actually ride with us you like what we
do and you're like we put out and you we
have a difference of opinion which is
great we could have a different opinion
every single [ __ ] day yeah in a weird
way exactly I don't agree with that and
you're stupid
I accept you and your weird girl dumb
for that your website yeah I was looking
at your feet yesterday yeah he was that
[ __ ] was man weird no we're in them
he got his feet next to his face like
why are you looking bro because his [ __ ]
look like statue he has some nice start
he has some nice I almost said Star of
David
what a part of the Jewish media yeah
yeah um he tried to comment on me and
not a gay way he like was thinking it so
hard like how to say it I wasn't a
compliment
your feet are statues what's your feet
out right now look up a goddamn statue
you got statue I don't think statues got
the nicest feet frankly frankly so it's
a compliment is not
I mean he got some he got some Allison
High Towers you know
he got some Alice said hi Powers you
know he was coming with the green coats
he got some quick coats bro
but to button this up I appreciate y'all
who all said that because it's okay
we're okay with disagreeing and you
understand what we're trying to do with
these jokes everybody who uses an
opportunity to just try to dunk on me so
you could uh impress your little Echo
chamber you're not fans of what I do
you're not fans of this podcast go [ __ ]
yourselves this is not for you at all
okay you might have agreed with us on
some other points go suck dicks and if
you can't I nominate your mother as
tribute yes okay okay now like a picture
and your mother would be a great pinch
hitter for something
[Laughter]
can't as always I don't want no smoke
with you lady
that lady is wild bro if she stink her
teeth in you oh you're [ __ ] it's a
problem
y'all nerd asses don't even know that no
in your gyms does your Mountain do you
know y'all even know all the dragons bro
Candace Owens is Valerian The Dread I'm
like in my head I'm like damn dude I cut
what I said about this [ __ ]
I got nothing bad to say about it it's
weird respect to Candace dude that's
weird yes 100 don't hurt me so you like
everything that she does you you stand
behind it don't hurt me please the
reason why we got these [ __ ] Nazis
listen to this
oh no that's both yeah
I'll be trying to what up each other on
this [ __ ] yeah red pill [ __ ]